-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show!"
I'm here with the one and only
Heidi Klum,
ladies and gentlemen.
And we're about to play a game
called "Auto-Tune Up."
Here we go.
-♪ Auto ♪
♪ Tune ♪
♪ Up, yeah ♪
[ Vocalizes ]
-Here's how it works,
we're going to take turns
hitting this button,
and it will select
a random,
boring paragraph.
And our job is to turn it
into an awesome song
with the help of Auto-Tune.
Are you ready for this?
-Yes.,
-I think it'll be great.
Alright. I will go first to show
you what we're doing.
Let's see what I'm auto-tuning.
Start the generator, please.
"A guide to spring break
in Daytona Beach, Florida."
So many things to do in Florida
on spring break.
Alright, here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
No idea.
-How are you so good at this?
-I had no idea what I said
or what was happening.
Alright. Get ready, Heidi.
It is your turn.
Let's see what's on,
the generator.
Let's start the generator.
Then you press this whenever
you're ready to stop it.
-"A negative Amazon review
for a dog stroller."
-Yeah. Alright, so someone
bought a dog stroller
and they posted
a negative review.
Now, Heidi Klum, you're going to
make this into a giant hit.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Distorted voice ]
♪ Ow! ♪
♪ Oh it did, oh it did ♪
♪ It did, it did,
it did, it did ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-How.
-You know.
You know what
the funny thing is?
-What?
-What the funny thing is,
you put this Auto-Tune on
I sound the same way
I always sound!
-No, no. It's not true!
-You tricked me!
-You sounded like you sung
that song or something before.
Okay. It is. It is -- right?
Okay, it's my turn.
Let's see what I'm singing.
Let's start the generator here.
"A list of Baylor University's
basketball coaching staff."
-Oh, Boy.
-So this is just a list
of Baylor University's
coaching staff.
Okay, here we go.
-Okay.
Alright.
Wish me luck.
♪♪
♪ And John Jakus ♪
♪ John Jakus ♪
♪ John Jakus, John ♪
♪ And finally ♪
♪ I said,
Alvin Brooks III ♪
♪ Yes, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm crying a little bit.
-I broke a sweat on that one.
Okay, our last song.
Let's start generator here.
-I need this thing at home.
-I know.
Oh, shoot.
-Wait.
-"A YouTube comment for
the Obi-Wan Kenobi trailer."
-That's right. So they just --
the trailer just came out.
This is a comment of the trailer
that was just
released on YouTube.
-Oh!
♪♪
♪ Fire emoji ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on now.
You also, you
have the moves as well.
That's a jam right there,
Heidi Klum.
I love you.
-Her new song "Chai Tea
with Heidi" is available now.